if you're in it right now and you don't
feel the accolades this is what hard
feels like and this is why most people
can't make it unfortunately Society
celebrates the start and the Finish if
you're running a marathon it's like you
sign up you get your number everyone's
rooting for you raise a certain amount
of money for cancer whatever it is and
then at the end everybody's hugging you
you get to say you ran a 26 you know 26
Mile thing but the people who win are
the ones who Master the middle it's the
26 miles where you have to just keep
going the brutal mindless unending
middle and the people who Master success
are the ones who Master the middle not
the ones who celebrate the beginning not
the ones who celebrate the end not the
ones who need the people celebrating but
literally one step at a time because the
person who loves the middle the person
who loves walking more than they love
the destination walks further than the
man who just loves the end